السادات لما حكم الرئيس الرئيس حكمنا بعد
رحيل جمال عبد الناصر سنه نهايه سنه 70
راحل عبد الناصر وبدا وبدا السادات
قرر ان هو يضرب الشيوعيين او الافنديات
ساعات افنديات كويس فقال لك ضربهم بايه
بطيار اخر التيار الديني وانه هوا مصر
شويه ممكن يروح نحو هذا التيار
[موسيقى]
طلعهم عبد الناصر انت عارف كان بيدخل
بعضهم السجون كان كان في يعني ايه نوع من
التعتيم على رسائلهم وكانت ما يقولوكا
يسخر احيانا منهم وله وله يعني بعض خطب
بيقولها فيها سخريه سخريه منهم فالمهم
لما اخرجهم فبدات كمان بقى في دعم برساله
او باخرى من شيخ زي الشعراوي يعني ثم دعم
سياسي في الموضوع انا بشوف انه وراها طبعا
لان التلفزيون الدوله مش ممكن الدوله كانت
هتسيبه يقدم اي رساله لو لم تكن هي راضيه
او مش بس راضيه تريد هذه الرساله